We will now like to generalize
the work energy theorem
to more than one dimension.
Remember that we defined
our work as an integral
from a to b of a force dot ds.
And graphically
let's look at that.
If we start at A and
we go to a point B, ,
and if at some point on
this path we have a force F,
and the displacement is
always tangent to the force
for an object M, we would like
to now figure out how this
integral is related to the
change in kinetic energy.
So first off, it's
always important
when analyzing a new
result to understand where
Newton's second law comes in.
And for our point particle
Newton's second law
is that the force
is equal to ma,
which we can write as mass times
the derivative of the velocity.
And so our first step is to
rewrite the work integral
and now to incorporate Newton's
second law into this integral.
So this is no longer
simply a concept of physics
but it's combining the second
law and our definition of work.
Now what I'd like to
do here is to note
that the displacement
of a particle
is always equal to
the velocity times dt.
So if we put that result in
here, AB of M dv dt dot v dt,
you can see that we can cancel
dt's, which is essentially
taking the time out
of this integral
and writing the work
entirely in terms
of the small change in
velocity, dv, scalar product
with the velocity.
And this is the quantity we
would now like to calculate.
So one way, when we ever want
to calculate these dot products,
we choose a coordinate system.
So let's choose a Cartesian
coordinate system,
plus x plus y, with our unit
vectors i-hat and j-hat.
Now our task is to write
down these various vectors.
So for instance,
dv can be written
as dv x i-hat plus dv y j-hat.
Now if we were to go
into three dimensions
we would have dv z
k-hat but I'm just
going to do this
in two dimensions.
Similarly, the velocity
is vx i-hat plus vy j-hat.
And now when we take
the dot product,
as we've learned in
Cartesian coordinates,
it's just the
components dv x vx,
and I'll just do a
little parentheses there,
plus dv y vy.
And so now, our
work integral, AB,
is equal to the mass times dv x
vx plus the mass times dv y vy.
Now what we have here is to
a sum in the [? integrant. ?]
But by the rules
of integration we
can rewrite this integral as
two separate integrals from A
to B of M dv x vx and
from A to B of M dv y vy.
And now we can integrate
each of these separately.
And if you recall,
in one dimension
we used our integral formula,
this is just vx squared.
And when we integrate them
what we have to look at
is the end points
of our integral.
What we're integrating
is a velocity,
and we're going from
some initial value
to some final value.
So our first integral simply
becomes M vx final squared.
I'll pull out the factor 2 minus
vx initial squared, where A vx
initial is the initial x
component velocity of A
in vx final is the
final component of B.
And I have a similar
term here, which
is vy final squared minus
the vy initial squared.
And when I combine
our terms, vx final
squared plus vy final
squared minus one-half M
vx initial squared plus
vy initial squared.
We've already shown that
our kinetic energy, 1/2 M v
dot v is 1/2 M vx
squared plus vy squared.
And so we see that this is
just the final kinetic energy
minus the initial
kinetic energy.
And so we can call that delta k.
And what we have now is
the work energy theorem.
And I'll come back to
my original statement
that the work is equal to
the change in kinetic energy.
And this is a combination
of our definition of work
and Newton's second law.